hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to agario I really
really whoa hey sex how's it going I
really like this game this game is
awesome it's addictive its competitive
it's a lot of fun and I've been playing
free-for-all mode a lot more which
people actually recommend it in the
comments in the last episode where I was
just playing teams ah no God zero I'm
not ready I was running my hands through
my hair I was being handsome in yes hi
Turkey
you missed me what a douche nozzle so
anyway I found a thing called agario
mods that allowed me to make custom
skins not everyone else I'm an unnamed
cell but I love looking at my own face
anyway free-for-all mode is way more fun
than team mode because it's just
complete insanity hello USA I've
consumed the entire America whoa Nelly
[ __ ] oh that was the wrong button
I meant to W that I Frick also another
thing that the mod adds is music hello
sex I got eaten by sex so what I'm gonna
do is I'm all packed up for any Popcaan
and this is the last video that I'm
gonna be recording before I head out on
my flight to hang out with Bob Jack and
Wade and I can't wait to go there
because it's gonna be a smaller
convention which means that it's gonna
be less intense as packs and other
places are and we're just gonna be able
to have fun and I'm gonna be able to
meet you guys and we do have a panel
scheduled for Saturday but I don't eat
me know I want to live I'm trying to run
oh [ __ ] well oh I don't know why that
guys not bursting on me yeah that's
right you better run I got viruses out
the whooing I do not have viruses out my
way see one of the big advantages of
going gung-ho especially when you're
small is that you can when you split
you're actually faster and then the two
pieces can combine or combine can gather
up more of these little ones but I mean
it is risky but you're faster so I mean
it's whatever
oh my god huh
oh [ __ ] this was a mistake I've done bad
please don't kill me
I'm whoa i whoa oh god zero gold zerah
you can do stuff like that which is
really cool
oh wait I'm not an unnamed cell hey I'm
on the leaderboard
I'm I fab uka peg which means that I'm
using a custom skin
it's the mod that makes it able to use
you our URL images so that's why I'm
that high ballsy how's it going hey
friend how you doing hey can I get you
know oh well I mean I wanted to get more
than that but hey that'll do I guess I
mean I could do a double but I don't
want to split me into for what yep okay
there we go Wow okay ah maybe it is a
size cuz I'm on the leaderboard but I'm
getting boobie dues from the Doobie
Dobby hello
oh god I can see everything now I can
see clearly now the rain is gone it's
really disconcerting when you get this
big because you realize oh I can see
this big but they probably also can also
see this hello well I did not know that
I was gonna eat that guy oh crap ah crap
ah crab crab whole rap dog
haha see now I am still on the
leaderboard god that didn't that didn't
go well for me but what it did do is it
knock down one of the bigger guys back
there or maybe it didn't I wasn't really
paying attention I was dying but to me
the game's not as fun unless you're
playing really aggressively and you're
taking big risks and doing lots of cool
things like this yeah dragger I spared
you I spared you I spared you dragger oh
god oh god yo Oh
believe it
I still don't thinking get me I'm pretty
sure got ya yeah he's only two upping
he's not 100 and I think it's over like
the rule is like you have to be 125
percent bigger than somebody ah yeah ah
god damn it oh so close
Oh dräger dragger drag your dragger drag
or Drakkar dragger okay no mercy for you
now Draeger
oh [ __ ] Oh shet ski oh I'm such an ass
can I pop this guy oh this guy's MIDI oh
my god that didn't go as well as I
thought it was gonna go let me reform
here that didn't work at all are you
doing wanna do something you want dance
you want dance fool you wanna dance fool
I didn't think so
I thought not I thought the opposite of
what your intentions were I thought the
thing that you thought a thought unless
yes
you're welcome wall jack no no see the
good thing is I'm slightly faster than
him
quit quit dick oh oh that was close when
I thought that guy was going to get zorb
got sandwiched between Big Mike and food
poisoning ah oh no no no no no no no no
oh I thought for sure he was gonna I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die I'm gonna die no
CJ no Wow okay
no you just made me a bigger target I'm
still alive
those guys are merciful those guys are
way more merciful than I would be
because I would eat them alive yay whoa
okay I'm on leaderboard now oh oh oh
give give help earth is coming after me
oh you so stupid you stupid and ugly and
snuggly and stupid what are you gonna do
nothing huh died yeah nothing that's
what I thought yeah that's what I
thought earth you're in a dangerous
place there buddy
ha ha ha I got you now or something
maybe I want oh come on no no it's so
stupid
I got you anyway now I'm just gonna
clean up the midsection of all this food
shouldn't leave your food out get
spoiled what are you doing I did it okay
I did it okay cool I did it I did
something hi Nick how's it going I'm in
the middle of a very stressful game
right now
the thing about this game for some
reason I don't like like competitive
multiplayer stuff but this game really
really gets my blood pumping I don't
even know what it is
it's just so relaxing and simple but I'm
just like whoa okay running away that's
no good
North no it's given my food my food yep
mine mine all mine earth you are so dead
earth you are so dead you don't even
know how dead you are Earth you're so
dead
ah
ah I'm good I did something I did a
thing didn't I did a thing I did a thing
I did a good thing I did a good I could
have gotten all of him if I to spend a
little more up on my trajectory but uh I
was too ecstatic that I actually did a
thing yaranaika is coming after me oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
no no no and I'm gonna reform oh my god
like a split second too early ah
man I just wanted to keep them close no
none of that none of that none of that
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] whoa what the oh [ __ ]
risky risky risky risky oh if I had
enough I could pop that guy oh yes yes
leaderboard now you're number one on the
suck board I need to work on my smack
talk I'm not good at it man very still
number one I guess no one was nearby to
take advantage of what I did sometimes I
don't know why these guys don't
hey this is cuz I take more risks than
others oh [ __ ] I will so eat this yes oh
yes I don't know what you were trying to
do there but thanks for the feed there's
someone whoop there's someone else and
yep okay
good good good got that oh no no no no
no no no no
no no no yes yes yes I got you Columbia
mmm I love Columbia fraiche room you're
damn right I'm gonna do that for
something as small as you cuz I have low
standards change in your mind you
probably should have changed your mind
Oh oh my oh my oh my oh my oh my oh my
and give give give give give dammit oh
oh no oh no oh no oh no gataki
shiitake shiitake shiitake shiitake Oh
God
my face my face my face my face my face
my face hurts my face hurts my face very
much hurts ow ow my face ow ow face face
face me eat face face is eaten face is
bad face isn't doing too good face is
doing real bad okay whoo Nellie thank
you thank you dude I will I will I will
spend resources just to pop you dude I
would have been fine if I did nothing I
would have been fine okay so either way
I've been playing for about 40 minutes I
got to prepare for my flight because I'm
leaving just a few hours but thank you
everybody so much for watching I hope
you really enjoyed this this game is
just so much fun
I really have nothing else to say about
that link in the description totally
free give it a try thanks again
everybody and let me know if you want to
see me playing more because it's always
fun to play and as always I will see you
in the next video
here's all of your concerns all that you
worry about in your daily life can just
melt away